alors pierre juquin vous avez vous êtes
entré au parti communiste en 53 vous
allez supporter l'époque des grèves
insurrectionnelles en allemagne de l'est
à berlin vous avez supporté budapest en
56 et tchécoslovaquie en 68 vous avez
participé à l'exclusion d'un certain
nombre de vos camarades et aujourd'hui
quel effet ça fait d'être exclue vous
même ce n'est pas mon principal problème
parce que je crois que la situation
beaucoup évolué depuis
d'autre part il ya deux ans j'ai écrit
un livre qui s'appelait autocritique et
sa tête et me de la frime
j'essaie de faire le bilan de tous a dit
réfléchir vraiment et j'avais deux
solutions ou me mettre à écrire des
romans ou des essais ou essayer de
repartir je ne dirais pas et romain
tenant compte de tout cela et de tout ce
qui s'est fait en dehors de moi pendant
ce temps pour continuer une bataille
disons humaniste
vous rejoignez la cohorte des repentis
du pc finalement reparti je trouve sur
votre est mauvais je vais vous dire
pourquoi peut-être pas que ce que vous
pensez vrai parce que moi je ne suis
jamais rentré dans le communisme comme
rendre dans une église
je pense qu'il faut enfin laïcisé ce
genre de politique dans le parti
communiste
j'ai beaucoup appris moi qui suis un
intellectuel évidemment d'origine très
modeste mais toute la base des lectures
elle et j'en suis fier et heureux je
vous dois l'être encore plus j'ai
rencontré là des gens de tous les
milieux du monde du travail mais je veux
parler des candidats - cheminots ont
directement passeport mais j'aime
tournage nous parle des gens vous avez
vu vous avait exclu à l'époque où des
choses insupportables que vous avez
supporté c'est vous le regrettez pas il
aura rendu service à partir d'extraits
j'en ai pas tellement exprimé j'ai
couvert des types de politiques non je
pas exclu à la criée j'ai couvert un
tibia les étudiants communistes et en 65
une bataille j'ai couvert un type de
politique dans les cavités qui est très
préjudiciable la cause de tirs est la
mienne celle du changement profond de
société ce que voulait pas bien en amont
un peu simpliste monsieur g15
rénovateurs ps eut lcr sos racisme et
que je écologistes n'ai pas peur d'être
le candidat pour tous la prochaine
élection présidentielle si j'étais le
candidat fourre-tout je me retire
lorsque ça je ne devais pas je crois
qu'il s'agit de faire quelque chose de
cohérent de sérieux je dirais de morale
là
la chose qui mobilise le plus et qui est
quand même le point de départ de ma
réflexion critique demande examen de
conscience c'est que j'en ai assez de
cette politique pour le faire et de dire
c'est pas la vérité dans les gens qui
vous soutiennent on retrouve des gens
comme alain krivine qui ont été quand
même vos ennemis non ça nous fait rien
demandé de retravailler avec eux tout
est si je pouvais être un réconciliateur
un fédérateur de gens extrêmement
différent je serais très content mais je
crois qu'il faut pas focaliser sur
krivine sur x ou y est pas faire naître
un peu le jaubert de la gauche celui d
ailleurs en fait on sait pas où il est
moi je sais très bien où je suis parce
que les gens qui sont avec moi c'est pas
krivine et ses jeux ses candidats donc
une oreille sur tiré qu'une seule
krivine vous soutiens qui va me suivre
mais je suis le candidat plutôt des gens
d'un certain nombre de gens qui se sont
battus dans le mouvement social ou qui
s'y battent le mouvement antiraciste le
mouvement des étudiants ils soutiennent
pas dans leur ensemble et en tant que
tel mais y'en a beaucoup ils sont auprès
de moi c'est une immense joie
moi je vais vous dire au mois de
octobre septembre dernier il ya
exactement un an je songeais à me
retirer de la politique active de la vie
publique
c'est quand même assez dur est devant ce
mouvement les étudiants auxquels a
participé par exemple mon fils je me
suis dit il ya quelque chose à faire et
c'est une joie formidable de me voir
avec david assouline qui s'étaient tous
et beaucoup d'autres gens qui incarnent
ce mouvement excusez-moi 3 il a des
chances de faire des points jusqu'à j'ai
toujours pensé que s'il ne restait que
jusqu'à il serait celui là
à propos de ce que vous avez dit vous
avez raison en disant il ay là il a fait
tout ça il a accepté
j'aurai la hongrie budapest tout ça
c'est du moins ce que je crois c'est que
personne ni personnellement je pense
qu'il faut pas reprocher éternellement
aux gens ce qu'ils ont fait a regardé à
tout faire mais attendez à partir du
moment où on est faits div je me suis
trompé j'ai dit des bêtises j'ai fait
des choses condamnables
je promets des gens à maya guerre parce
que sur quoi d'avoir fois-là l'adoration
n'aurait pas dû une fois l'arrêt ce que
je veux dire non non la comparaison mais
j'allais prendre moi-même c'est cette
comparaison
on dit toujours faut-il éternellement
rechercher à faire le procès des gens
qui ont été collaborateur ou quad et
vichysme je dis non si quelqu'un
aujourd'hui qui a été vite chis dit mais
c'est horrible j'en ai honte j'en dors
pas la nuit etc
jeudi mais il faut complètement oublié
le seul problème c'est qu'il ya beaucoup
de gens qui continuent à être vichysme
ou qui continuent à trouver qu'ils
avaient raison d'être collaborer
incompétent alors cela il faut être
implacables
ouais totalement un placard mais quand
quelqu'un reconnu pour être tout le
monde s'est trompé un moment donné
absolument tout le monde
tout le monde a été ou maoïste ou
communistes ou ou petit liste ou ou
accrue au socialisme au libéralisme pur
et dur tout le monde s'est trompé
donc forcément si on veut faire quelque
chose on ne peut le faire qu'avec les
gens qui reconnaissent qu'ils se sont
trompés
forcément alors faisons là la grande
unité des gens qui reconnaissent qu'ils
se sont trompés
le par contre aux assistants trompait
contre les gens qui continue à tromper
voilà celui qu un georges
est un peu triste de ce qui vient de se
passer et il a accepté tout à fait
officieusement puisque
n'a pas voulu il n'a pas souhaité être
filmé il a accepté de venir avec nous
dans la rue pour faire un micro trottoir
mais surtout si vous le rencontrez vous
ne lui répétez pas c'est totalement
secret on va voir
est ce que est ce que vous êtes concerné
par l'exclusion de pierre juquin du
parti communiste français dans la sacem
a highway alors là non la chine je suis
absolument sûr que vous n'avez pas
choisi cette dame au hasard c'est
impossible vous soyez pas concernés par
un problème qui ôte qui concerne
normalement la vie politique française
et et vous êtes d'accord avec le comité
central du parti communiste français
quand il
il a exclu pierre juquin et bien sûr
voilà l'envoyer voyez que nous aussi
nous sommes des rénovateurs c'est ce que
je dis excusez moi on va l'amener dans
le studio
mais vous savez ces veaux à faire un jeu
c'est pas savez moi la politique les
comprends pas dans ceux aux actes ah je
suis d'accord il n'a qu'à respecter la
ligne du parti communiste
il n'y a pas il n'y a pas de tests dans
partie habituellement une savez c'est un
ami personnel 1 en dehors de toute
question politique
moi j'ai toujours eu une grande
affection bon pied indiqué jeudi qu'il
faut plus leurs pompes parce qu'il a
connu une trop forte erreur quand on est
un membre du parti en août où il était
placé et où il avait d'accord avec tous
ses camarades depuis de nombreuses
années maintenant
il a tu es sûrement traîné par la
bourgeoisie comme les doriot et marchal
as ennuis il a été intégré par eux et
eux ils à la bourgeoisie s'en sert de ce
gala si vous voulez revenir
personnellement je suis prêt à lui
ouvrir les bras c'est un
vous lancez monsieur machin fait tout à
fait je viens avec nous sans le savoir
comme slogan c'est normal non bon voilà
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
enfin vocabulaire merci pour lui on va
maintenant on a fait un autre canular
on va voir qui vous concernent moins
c'est que comme vous allez piquer
beaucoup de voix genre marché moi je
suis sûr que vous faites quoi oui enfin
la joie ni oui je suis sûr que votre
candidature va marcher moi
personnellement parce que vous regrouper
un courant qui n'est pas représenté au
niveau des élections présidentielles et
on a imaginé que marchés disent aux gens
que pour arriver à faire des voix pour
le pc et allait être obligé de
s'associer avec le front national
et vous allez voir ce que ça donne
j'étais choisi complètement au hasard
j'en suis ravie reloge j'avais une
question à vous poser d'abord vous avez
sans doute voté aux dernières élections
oui voilà vous avez voté pour nous
peut-être pas du tout à
alors il vanta voilà c'est là où je me
méfie un petit peu des médias oui est-ce
que vous avez voté communiste aux
dernières élections non à à l'envoyer là
encore une fois voilà je parle dans le
dans le studio vous me voyez pas je
suppose à l'image mais on est en train
d'essayer comme d'habitude de me piéger
ce à dire qu'on met des gens qui sont
pas concernés par la politique c'était
si c'est carrément un complot vous avez
monté là vous avez voté communiste
oui oui même un tout petit peu plus que
communiste et vous avez voté communiste
oui évidemment on l'avait alors voyez
pas ce que ça ces problèmes la
télévision on met des gens qui sont
convaincus déjà alors comment voulez
vous qu'on ait un dialogue et qu'on est
des gens à convaincre alors là bien sûr
cette dame a été prise au hasard dont la
wii non non mais d'accord mais enfin le
hasard fait quand même bien les choses
c'est un peu comme la cravate rouge des
journalistes là c'est un journaliste du
figaro vous m'avez mis là la non écoute
et je crois que le débat n'est pas
autour de ma cravate le débat est de
savoir si non mais moi je réponds je
réponds sur le plateau et j'ai quand
même l'impression que
il ya des grèves ou poser la question
que pose ce monsieur combien à combien
vous estimez le pourcentage que vous
allez faire au premier tour en belgique
on arrivera à 40% à je crois pas mais
pourquoi on n'y arriverait pas parce
qu'on a justement nation c'est une
alliance avec des partis comme le front
national on fait comme les autres
on y arrive moi j'espère à un but de 9%
- ah mais vous êtes carrément pessimiste
mais moi moi je pense qu'il y aura quand
même plus
oui à l'ajustement nous on a en a un
problème au parti communiste et ses de
s'associer à d'autres partis pour
arriver à faire 35 à 40% au premier tour
c'est ça qu'il nous faut oui mais il est
socialiste et ils sont mous la voilà
c'est ça le problème les socialistes
sont mous oui excusez moi
alors non mais vous avez raison de le
dire et vous préférez qu'on s'associe
avec des parties durent de gauche tous
ensemble aulas plutôt que de la droite
pactise avec le front national
il ya aucune raison que le parti
communiste ne fasse pas la même chose à
votre avis riche entièrement d'accord ah
ça me fait plaisir que des gens
puisqu'ils perdre et ils sont pris au
hasard répondent affirmativement est ce
que vous êtes d'accord avec cette
tactique
voilà on met en face de moi des gens qui
sont pas du tout conservé pour la
politique française sur ça c'est
scandaleux
j'avais une question
à poser ce que vous penseriez d'un
système politique qui réunit ray
conjointement la privatisation la
nationalisation le libéralisme et le
laxisme fondamentale inhérent à toute
civilisation décadente par rapport à la
situation internationale que tu es suis
désolé mais à me poser cette question
comme ça moi j'ai pas visite de parler
alors j'ai pas évident de parler comme
ça l'antenne en direct je peux pas
répondre comme ça précisément cette
question est peut-être que si vraiment
ça vous intéresse de savoir ce que j'en
pense on pourra en parler en privé
ah mais si on peut s'arranger un rendez
vous savez moi je suis pas content
faudrait que les liens ne soient pas là
forcément ce que tu crois michael que
pierre juquin à une chance d'après son
thème astral que tu as étudié en
fonction de sa date de naissance de son
lieu de naissance de son or de naissance
est ce que pierre juquin à une chance
oui venons d'être président de la
république en mai 88 noms haye a
salement parlant inapte aux cultures dur
aucune chance laurent heureusement je
pense que le public va ressentir que
vous êtes un être terriblement affectif
dans votre des tennis tôt et qui va vous
accordez très largement sa sympathie
d'un trafic de jupiter qui va vous
ouvrir énormément le coeur des français
reste france d'autre part je pense que à
travers la lutte qui va se produire au
moment de mes 88 les élections vous
allez vous réaliser d'une certaine
manière et qu'avec le retour de saturne
vous à les concrétiser le nouvelle
association les corrections de nourrir
un t2 il a l'habitude abonnez vous il
m'était impossible ou